it's a book promoting vegetarianism if
someone gets me a book against Islam I
will say that book is false excuse me I
don't allow a debate between the
audience and the speaker the audience
just put the question the speaker can
only answer the question don't get
involv I will not allow Dr Zakir neither
Mr zi to get involved in any debate with
the audience this is not a debate time
for the audience kindly note you can
continue with the answer I'm going to
start with the answer you can start the
timing also if I'm going to be
interrupted every time I want to give a
complete answer I would request the
chairperson not to be biased towards one
person only if they're interrupting my
answer I have to be given
time and the sister raised an argument
which is there not only in this book
even other books on internet you go to
the Internet the same argument is
given first thing is that is milk veg or
nonv is a big question there are
vegetarians who say that milk is
nonv this book I'm not blaming the
speaker this book again says milk is
non-v if you have milk so many diseases
other vegetarian Foundation say no we
are lacto vegetarian we have milk
whether milk is non-v or veg my simple
question is if you don't want to hurt
the animals when you milk when you milk
the animal it causes severe pain you
know artificial minking of animal causes
pain you ask a breastfeeding woman
certain time she has problems and she
has to extract milk artificially it is
so painful so when you extract milk from
the animal it's painful when you don't
agree that animals are meant for food
how can you milk the animals the cattle
and the cow it is so painful it is
nothing but robbing the animal if you
say the animal is not meant for food and
if you have the milk of that animal
you're robbing the milk which is meant
for the offsprings for the Cales and the
example that was given that a cow on
average in a day gives 10 cages of
milk again this book if it's wrong no
problem problem it on the internet also
10 kgs of milk in a day in a month 300
kgs in a year about 3,000 kg do you
calculate milk in kges in liters why in
kges I don't know ask the author and
then further it says that 3,000 kgs of
milk it will feed 6,000 people so in
full lifetime it will feed 90,000 people
at one time and the car if you kill only
1,000 people which is better ,000 or
1,000 why are you killing the goose that
laying the golden egg daily it's not a
wise proposition and I agree with that
but the point to be noted is that no
Milkman will ever give a milking cow to
the slaughter house no slaughter house
will ever purchase a milking cow because
a milking cow is multiple times more
expensive than a cow which has passed
its age of milking in Bombay it cost 20
to 25,000 rupees milking cow an old cow
which has crossed the milking Age cost
only three to 5,000 rupees so what we do
we nonvegetarians the cattle we look
after it till the time it gives milk
after startop giving milk we Slaughter
it we take all the eggs of the goose
when it stops laying we Slaughter the
goose for it
[Applause]
flesh two birds with one stone we are
more intelligent
again the argument giving that see some
animals you can use them in field Etc
you can use them for plowing for
transportation if you love The Animals
so much why do you overload them and
furthermore the Indian stat tells us
that out of the population of cows oxes
and bull only 25% are productive the
remaining 75% are unproductive either
past the age of milking or they are
males all done females Bulls oxes now
what will you do with the 75% of excess
nonproductive cow
goat Bulls Ox one option you rare them
up yourself an average bull OA requires
18,000 a year for living according to
the statistics their statistics not my
statistics 18,000 a year so after they
give milk they live another four five
years which farmer will bear the burden
of millions of cow every year 18,000
second option is give to J the
organization they leave it open it
enters the field eats up the crop third
option leaves them in a jungle animal
will kill them the last option is best
after they reach the age of milking
utilize the milk give it to SL houses it
benefits the farmer he gets some money
and even the animal benefits the human
being by eating the meat of the animal
as well as his height for leather as
well as the bones hope that answer the
question next question for Mr
zavi according to St Chan Jen in the
marriage of the 22nd
tankar Alis Nami popularly known as
namat meat of animals and birds was
served and both the bride and the
bridegroom according to shastra were
Jans another incident was quoted that
chaina a Jan shika who was the wife of
bimar shik a contemporary of mahavir was
pregnant and she had the desire to eat
the heart of her
husband bim's eldest son abay Kumar
instead gave her some meat of a dead
animal and Cha thinking it to be her
husband's heart ate it I don't know how
authentic is this article and whether
What kastur chan said is true or false
what is its explanation please explain
I'm referring to uh to the article from
the Caravan series December
1981 thank you sister first of all I
will request the coordinator to only
allow those questions coming out of my
talk not out of any other book or other
references for which I am not
responsible but because I am a true Jane
I know definitely about the Jane history
about nein tankar yes it is true that
this is why he propagated that the
killing of that is exactly why he
renounced the world that for my marriage
are you going to sacrifice all these
innocent creatures no I don't want such
a fish for me and that is why he became
a Jan monei and ultimately a tankar so
that is why I can say that all Jan taras
have absolutely in absolute terms have
prohibited non-wage food thank you and
please restrict your questions to my
talk only not because it seems
I don't know it seems that these books
were given in all good faith that they
should understand our Viewpoint it seems
that they are all distributed to those
people and there are now asked to ask
questions I don't think that is fair you
can ask me any question from my talk I
will be very uh happy to say I will
request any any question can be asked on
the
topic the thing is there whether it's in
the talk or
out uh not necessarily the and another
point I will tell Mr coordinator that Mr
YP trii and myself we both have got
other meetings so we would like to
conclude within 5 minutes what I would
suggest see the time given to both the
speakers to speak was 5050 minutes then
15 15 minutes was for response then we
would have a question answer session for
50 minutes if any of the speakers would
like to Forfeit the time of not carrying
on with the question session and if they
have an emergency I would excuse them
but I would continue the question
session for 50 minutes because that has
what been the chart given to me I have
to execute it like I had been told Dr
Zak cannot in his talk or response speak
on any other religion forcefully got him
not to speak on it I'm telling you
forcefully I had to convince him you
cannot touch anything else I got him
convinced because that was the request
his respect now both what both speakers
have agreed to I have followed that
anything which both speakers don't agree
I've thrown it out let me be very clear
we have said 50 minutes we love minutes
but if one speaker would like to leave
early for any emergency or any
requirement a person has got a full free
will and a choice I would respect that
requirement but we'll continue question
answer for 15 minutes I've written down
the time
12:45 close down at around
1:30 right so I think that is being very
fair and clear on my part the next
question for Dr Zakir assalam alaykum
Zakir by my name is KH Abdul Sami and my
question to you is food value charts are
distributed by vegetarians showing that
the proteins and iron content of
vegetarian food is higher than nonv food
and thus they say veg food is more
nutritious than non food your comments
please thank
you asked a very good question I would
like to reply to the question posed by
the learnning speak also he doesn't know
who distributed them it's given in
writing out here it's given by RAB
Foundation to irf saying we would be
pleased to give you more such material
in huge quantities if you like the same
to be circulated among Muslim Brothers
in Mumbai free of
charge the brother has asked a question
that there are fruit charts being
distributed yes even we get in our
foundation we didn't respond thinking
that it is it's not worth responding
it's not worth responding but when the
request came from the rushab foundation
are you willing I reluctantly agreed you
know it is not a topic of scientific
thing it's a well-known fact he said yes
we'll I said fine so I'm here just
replying why should people get irritated
if you can quote me from any book as
long as within the topic I will insh
answer if I don't
know I will say I don't know if I know I
will say no I know your question and
even I got that chart it gives food
value chart saying that proteins among
the W food is more than non-v food and
even Mr rash a in his talk he said that
the value of
proteins the quantity is
more Mr rash said that there were only
three essential amino acids you ask any
doctor it is not three it is
eight no wonder five is
lacking it is eight essential amino
acids which are not synthesized in the
body the remaining are synthesized these
essential Amo I said should be given by
the external food source the proteins of
animal Foods they're biologically
complete known as higher protein because
they contain all the eight essential
amino acids the veeg protein are lacking
in one or more of the essential amino
acids it's a scientific answer so even
though the value may be more 20 up 10
down it is not
complete the veeg protein the incomplete
protein of lesser quality animal protein
is of higher quality and complete
protein similarly if you analyze even
the iron you get from the that is of two
types one is hamion one is non hamion
hon can be absorbed easily in the body
non hamion cannot be absorbed easily in
the animal food there is H as well as
non-h the vegetable food contains very
little H therefore they cannot absorb
therefore there's more deficiency of
iron in them so even a agree with you
the iron content in figures may be high
the protein content be higher down the
conclusion is veg food is more nutritive
it's misleading the people it's nothing
but misleading I would call it in plain
English fraud who's doing it some
vegetarian Society misleading the
people and fraud is prohibited in every
religion small
Lobby where the major minor religion
fraud is prohibited
so I would like to ask a question would
you
prefer taking 10 notes 10 notes of rupes
20 or one note or rupes
500 if you know the value for money you
choose the second hope the answer is the
question the next question for Mr zi
asalam alikum I am ja shik my question
is to
Rashmi Rashmi in your talk you mentioned
that diseases transmitted through meat
flesh to human beings but uh plants also
affected by some diseases viral
bacterial diseases so you can get
diseases from plant vegetarian food also
you also mention Dean ornish and Deepak
Chopra references and recommendation of
those
doctors uh if you believe in
recommendations of doctors and medical
professionals Tria also mentioned that
if you believe in that I will quote only
simple example when I was child doctors
when I was suffering from fever doctors
were suggesting that don't take bath by
cold water but nowadays they telling
when I get fever they're telling that
please take bath by cold water only huh
see so if you are believing in
quotations statistical data and uh
Medical
things so please give statistical data
Dr Zakir Nik mentioned survey of America
regarding coronary heart disease so do
you have any statistical data regarding
coronary heart disease in India whether
is affected to more susceptible to those
who are having diet vegetarian diet or
to non-vegetarian
di I would request you all to put your
question briefly please the question is
so long that don't forget last part is
question coronary heart
disease see regarding coronary heart
disease yeah plants also if you consume
the decayed plant plant food I mean the
decayed fruits definitely it will carry
jums the point here is that the um
animals that carry the jums they are
more dangerous and they are likely to
carry more diseases than plant another
thing is is that which I have said is
that animal food contains excessive
protein cholesterol and saturated fat so
these two things combined that will make
uh non-w food prohibitive coming to the
statistics I have got that book it there
is no time there is not a platform to
argue about the Statics I have got
complete statistics that more people are
suffering because of heart disease those
who are fles eaters and the W people now
I at the moment I cannot give you those
facts and figures that I have got it
then I can supply it to you later thank
you no counter question please yes the
next question for Dr
Zakir asalam alikum brother uh brother
my name is safia I'm a r to Islam uh my
question is
uh uh in the book vegetarian or
non-vegetarian choose for yourself by
gopinath uh agar well uh there are
quotations given from major world
religions including Hinduism and
Christianity that nonvegetarian is
forbidden permitted and how do you say
it's
permitted s ask the
question that there are quotations from
the same book quoting various major
world religions like Christianity and
Hinduism saying that in that religion it
is prohibited so how come I said that
there is not a single major religion
which says that non-v food in general is
prohibited I clarified the Islamic
Viewpoint it's a misquotation out of
context
misunderstanding I do agree one thing
that there are certain quotations
sometimes nonv food is prohibited even
in
Islam like for example the verse I
quoted Sur ma 5 vers number one it says
that don't do hunting in pilgrimage
within the sacred pilgrimage don't do
hunting if you are fasting in the month
of Ramadan sunrise to sunset don't have
non-v food don't even have veg food
if I say don't have nonv food during
fasting that doesn't mean non-v food is
prohibited prohibited only during that
time so similarly there are quotation in
the religious scriptures at certain time
in fasting don't have non-v food regard
the question in Christianity and I've
read that book therefore I can
reply they say that in the Bible it is
mention that you can't have dead food in
brackets they put meat it's not there
what the quoting the reference is not
given I being a student of compar
village and I give talks on diets also
and they're referring to the Book of
Leviticus chapter number 17 verse number
15 as well as the book of Deuteronomy
chapter number 14 verse number 21 it
says that thou shal not have the meat
that D of itself dead meat is prohibited
not all meat dead meat they say dead
food and bracket meat it is dead meat is
prohibited even in the Quran Bak 2 ver
173 5 vers number 3 6 ver 145 16 vers
115 for for you for food are dead meat
blood the Flesh of swine and any food on
which any name besides Allah has been
invoked where it is allowed if you read
the book of Genesis chapter number n
verse number 2 and three it
says
that they will fear you they will dread
you all creatures of the Earth
all fowls in the sky all creatur that
liveth on the earth as well as all the
fishes in the
sea they shall be delivered to you next
verse Genesis 9:3 says that every
creature that
moveth on land and is the living
creature they are meat unto you and also
herbs and shrubs mention the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 14 verse
number n that he shall have the meat of
all the things in the water all that as
fins and scales you shall eat
Deuteronomy chapter number 14 verse
number 11 says that you shall have the
lawful meat of the birds Deuteronomy
chapter number 14 verse number 20 says
that he shall eat the meat of the lawful
fowls it's
allowed further if you read it's
mentioned in the book of Hebrews chapter
number
five verse number 13 and 14 that if you
have milk you you are weak if you have
strong meat you're powerful in reasoning
Bible says that not
I in the Gospel of Luke chapter number
24 only quotations verse number 41 to 43
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him goes in
the room and he says have you any meat
to eat and the disciples gave him a
piece of broil fish and honeycomb fish
and he ate before them Jesus Christ
peace be upon him in the Book of Romans
chapter number 14 verse number 2 and
three it says that one who believeth in
eating all things he can eat those who
are weak they only eat herbs and shrubs
but anyone who eateth should not insult
those who eateth not and those who
eateth not should not judge those who
eate it this is law of
God Hindu scriptures if you read the law
of Manu chapter number five verse number
30 it's clearly mentioned
that the eater can eat any creature that
lives even if he eats every day a
Creator created some creatures to eat
and some to be
eaten laws of Manu Manu smti chapter
number five verse number 31 it says that
eaten a sacrifice this is a law of a
god Manus chapter number five 42 it says
that a twice Bor
yes
brother no
please
please I'm always prepared I'm always
prepared when I quote scriptures
therefore it's not on
the answer
therefore I kept it behind otherwise my
books are in the front always they're
compelling me to reply therefore I'm
replying it's within the rules of the
debate I haven't completed
yet I have to speak for 5
minutes we we would request anyone not
to disturb in between please don't
disturb the question who disturbing
another 20 seconds you know because this
Wast time you know and then my time is
up I will stop the speaker no but
someone disturb me I should get more
time okay
we complete the answer in 30 seconds
it's further mentioned in the manusi
chapter number five verse number 35 you
can have me in r book number
10 himym number 16 verse number 10 you
can have meet rig book number 10 himym
number 85 verse number 13 r book number
10 himn number 86 verse number 13 says
the same thing you can have meat in
Mahabharat anushasan chapter 88 if you
read bishma gives the advice to udish
it's also mentioned in Manus smiti
chapter number three verse number 266 to
272 it's mentioned there that if you
want to please your ancestor if you give
Hubbs and shvs you will gratify them
only for one month if you give fish for
two months if you give venison the Flesh
of deer for 3 months if you give mutton
for 4 months if you give flesh of bird
for five months if you give goat meat
for 6 months if you give spotted deer
for 7 months if you give meat of black
Antelope for 8 months if you give cow
one full year if you give bull it is 12
years and if you give rhinoceros and red
meat of goat forever
inexhaustible so if you have to satisfy
your ancestors according to rig you have
to give more you have to give red meat
[Applause]
assalam alaikum my name is gulam and
this question goes to Mr zavi uh sir in
uh your dialogue you said Jane munis
don't kill plants they ask for arms so
is it that they force others to kill
plants for them or is it that when they
put masks on their face they are not
killing the germs and others are killing
the germs by not putting the mask on the
face what is it please clarify it's a
very good question sister I'm really
very happy of all the questions I would
definitely give you first number because
it it is said in Jane religion that you
should not kill anybody you should not
allow anybody to kill and you should not
appreciate if one kills so all these
three things are there so if a Jan monei
comes to know that this food is prepared
for him he will not take it so this is
the rule of Jan monei when they come to
us for begging they ask us very clearly
we also know that they will ask us have
you prepared anything for us we have to
very honestly say we have not prepared
anything it is for us we have prepared
say four chapatis he will take only one
we will be happy with three this is the
way of begging of a Jane money he will
not kill he will not allow other to kill
he will not propagate killing he will
not even eat if he comes to know that
this food is prepared for a Jane money
I'm happy that in this August and
enlightened audience I have been given
an opportunity to clear the viewpoints
of Jane Muni thank you very much uh and
I will now request coordinator that uh
Mr trii and myself it is really going on
so nicely we would like to continue here
for hours together but I am sorry that
last two questions we allow 5 minutes I
don't think it will be uh I think uh we
have been talking so much about
vegetarian food and nonvegetarian food
but we are all hungry
now I think we should go and eat so only
last two questions and then we dispers
the Mr tredia said we'll allow last two
questions on the mic uh when can we have
the next question for Dr
Zakir yes AA there's a request
for uh
Mr for you want to ask question
to no but they should have to follow but
I think you should have come up in the
queue you
know
huh my question for Zak
is are non-vegetarian food deficient
there is a request from the other what
we will do we will what I will do see
but there's a request from the side
allow one or two people to ask questions
to Dr Zakir what I would suggest let the
speakers in the time they're available
here let the other two speakers ask
question then Mr Tred and Mr can leave
then I will give the chance so that I'm
not unfair to you also both people so
that no I've told them they wanted to
leave so I have to give them an
opportunity to leave they wanted those
two people to ask question they can ask
Dr Zakir which are the two people Mr zi
uh Mr bu and uh the
chance then after that we will carry on
with the other two people will be given
chance so that I'm not unfair to them I
hope the audience bears with me for
another 10 Mr Tri and Mr Z would like to
leave after that so let those two people
ask
question a we allow only no no no is
leaving let let us ask two questions to
him and let him hear yes okay yes let us
also ask a question let those people ask
question uh which Mr zav has requested
Mr B who's Mr
B Mr B and
that and the other two they two will
allow them to ask two questions to one
to Dr
Hussein excuse me Mr
zo ask okay now one question for yes one
question he'll ask one you ask then then
I will allow Mr Z after you all have
finished your two questions and one
minute after they finished the two
question you finish your two I'll allow
them to leave then the other two who
have missed their chance will be given
permission beyond that those who are
missing because of these two people will
be giving a chance beyond that I will
not allow please we have to complete the
program yes
sir short to the point Dr sir Dr brief
Kish sir yes brief and point question is
this
I went to see the
picture there was session of three days
people they were wearing sandal woods
and then beside that not eating any non
food no haircut nothing complete
brahmachari syasi when the picture was
over I asked them what is this those
three days complete
renunciation brahmachari what reply they
gave he
said
question please reply to me that those
three days they were offering what about
the whole world where killing should not
be stopped everywhere especially in
India
so we will not allow that
question sir on the request of the chief
guest and the speaker will not allow
that answer maybe have the Mr Rashmi zi
requested the person to ask a question
out of
turn I'm willing to
answer I'm willing to
answer if chairman says no if chairman
says no Then I will
to I would love to answer if you allow
me okay anyway I will control the
nothing will go wrong okay we'll allow
him but a short this what what was the
question I didn't hear it I heard the
question I'm supposed to
[Applause]
answer it's a very good question okay
now quickly and a quick answer then
we'll allow the other gentle it's a very
good question yes it's a very good
question it will not create problems I
believe though you are vegetarians out
here we aren't that violent it won't
create problems I take guarantee I will
not say something that will create
violence yes I know there are nonv and
veg Meats in Amad and Gujarat and there
were rights and all here as far as I'm
concerned I speak logical there nothing
happen the better asked a very good
question he said that he had seen
pilgrims going and for 3 days
they didn't have meat they didn't have
meatl it's on Islam it's on Islam Islam
I like no he asked a question on Islam
question on Islam not asking on
jism what's the problem are you so much
afraid that the answer will make him a
non-v he will yet be a veg no problem I
don't want you to become a
nonv the brother asked a very good
question that why there don't you have
nonv it's a misinformation I've been for
several times whoever told you told you
a lie that we don't have nonv the rule
out there is that in that sacred part at
that time you cannot kill any animal for
hunting at that time only but not eating
nonv I have gone there I eat nonv who
says you can't eat nonv yes we are
dressed up in two pieces of unstone
cloth you know why you know why because
it's the biggest annual gathering in the
world people come from America from
Canada from India from Pakistan from
Indonesia all dressed up in two pieces
of unsown cloth identical you cannot
make out the person next to you whether
the king or a papa for Universal
Brotherhood not theoretical practical
Universal
Brotherhood when we offer Salah we offer
Salah shoulder Tosh shoulder we eat food
we eat together we eat even nonv where
you got this from I don't know whoever
told you whether Muslim or non-muslim he
has told you total
falsehood I'm telling you I've been for
several time I've been forra is totally
wrong and for Universal Brotherhood
everyone comes there so that you can
make out people from various parts of
the world we have to be one Brotherhood
Islamic brotherhood is that all human
beings are brothers and Muslims are
brothers in faith yes
brother Mr zi this question is for
you at the end of your speech Mr Z this
question is for you please
yes put for any question Mr Z is having
his attention
there Mr zi this question is for you at
the end of your speech you have listed
16 points differentiating between the
herous animals and the carnivorous
animals now I don't feel there is anyone
in the audience to know this differences
except that you want to emphas you want
to give emphasis on the point that being
giving the comparisons of herous animals
you want to show you want to reflect
that we humans should also be
herbivorous that is we should be
vegetarian this is what I understand
Z Dr Zakir has already put has already
touched few of the points now Dr Zakir
and Mr zav I'm not a medical student by
profession I'm an engineering student I
had biology only up to my 10th standard
and thereafter only I gathered some
knowledge from here and there ask your
question please question now here the
points which I want to get a comment
from your side is that you have said
that pyin is there in the saliva of the
heror animal it is there in the carnos
animals and it is there present in the
humans also so now you have said that
herbus animals rotate their Joys while
eating I have never seen a seen a man
rotating his Jo it's a question of your
if you want to put a question you are
most welcome it's not a lecture session
we are not here to hear your impressions
if you are you are most welcome to ask
me a question say ask me a direct
question I'll be too willing to give you
a
reply both and myself we have got other
appointments we'll be leaving after this
you ask your question in three to four
sentences
that's all to four sentences what was
the need for you to give the
differentiate differentiation between
herbus and carnivorous animals what do
you want to emphasize yeah it is a very
natural thing that when I stated that
almost all Limbs and parts of the body
of human being are very similar to
herbivorous animals it is for the
enlightened audience to decide whether I
say whether you agree with me not if you
agree it's well and good otherwise if
you don't agree then also well and good
who am I to say that you must agree on
one point or others that's okay because
what I have stated is a scientific fact
which I have got reasons and I got proof
for that but it is for the audience to
see whether it is uh you are agreeable
to that or not my only point was that by
Nature a human being is more not not not
only more but 100% he is herbivorous and
by certain circumstances or by some
other reasons he has been made a
carnivorous now friends I must tell you
that I'm extremely delighted to be here
this morning and sharing our views and
so many misconceptions about Islam is
now cleared by our learned Dr Jakir we
never knew that these things are said in
Islam and for that I'm extremely
thankful to Islam Research
Foundation and I am also thankful to my
friend Mr Sala rushab foundation and
because of the time constraint of Mr Tri
and myself because we have got other uh
engagements we will uh take your uh
leave and again thank you very much Mr B
Mr B has to ask yes your Mr B yes no
well excuse me Mr B has been requested
especially to be given a chance to ask
question we have honored that request
and he will be given a chance now after
that Mr TR the last question from that
side and then yes last question from
there ladies I think a lesson number so
we disallow those two questions which
are missed out I hope that would be fair
Mr
tried yes Mr B then you and then we
finish the
session yes Mr har to
Hindus sorry after we conclude the
session two people will get a chance to
hear Dr Z if you want to hear the answer
those who want to hear can stay back
others can go yes Mr Bad har om to
Hindus J JRA to J Salam alikum to Muslim
bayum Asam uh request to Dr Zakir I have
all the answers of all your 20 questions
but that will not allow kindly give me
chance any any time you will get the
logical answers of all the 20 Questions
number
one now uh y all the religions follow
the God God God is Almighty now that
means one should should follow the
follow his rules also now what is given
by the god the rules formed of by the
God the same rule I appli to the last
speaker put your question in five
sentence assume Dr Zakir and Mr zi know
the background ask your question six
sentences asking you the question
ESS plenty of is available abundant
avable is available now other thing is
food which is which I'm coming to the
question the food bhagan has given us
the food also
one second question I'm
tell whatever easily is available he has
given is plenty now the whatever he has
given is plenty is cheaper and what
whatever he says no it is not to be
taken or it is districted should be uh
he has made it costly so are we
following the rule of to God sir what is
your question on this topic very
understood very I've understood the
question very long question very good
question see I'm in the field I can make
out the question I'm in the field they a
first part that you can answer all 20
points I have got various students in
this field I'll ask one of my students
to have a dialogue at irf if you want
anytime which date next Sunday next
Sunday not me my student next Sunday I
can I can answer to anybody next Sunday
anybody next Sunday anybody okay done
next Sunday you're invited what's your
name name everything will be given Mr B
will come to irf at 10:30 find 10:30
morning Sunday same format here and my
student will debate
anyone same
topic his question that God has provided
air right water everything easily
available so why go for things which are
uneasily available and costly very good
question that you have to point out to
Mr zavi he's telling that vegetables
should be transported to Arctic
Circle vegetabl should be transported to
to deserts tell him I didn't say that
I'm saying if vegetable available have
vegetable if animal is available have
the lawful animal you have to POS that
question to him not to me Point number
one you should have easily available
food as long as it is is awful we should
have expensive food you told me it's
like I telling a rich person why are you
living in nimman point you know one
square ft of land apartment niman Point
cost 25,000 rupees come to mea Road only
1,000 rupees per square F feet when the
rich man can afford to pay money to buy
a good flat why are you preventing a
rich man to buy good food and nonv food
in protein in and in various medically
it is superior it's of higher quality so
if rich man can afford it why are you
stopping if you can't afford have
vegetables I'm not stopping you hope
that answer the
question thank you for your enthusiasm
we'll not allow that question Mr zavia
said he would like to he's exhausted and
we respect his views uh he would like to
leave so we'll not allow that question
but we'll allow two people here who are
to ask questions after Mr zavian leave
because I promised them just
yes Mr danra slea would propose a vote
of thanks after which those who would
like to leave may leave those who would
like to hear those two questions and two
answers May s ex me one question from
the L
side it's not working hello the meeting
would be formally closed only two
questions after the meeting would be
allow
hello excuse me this is one last
question from the
ladies this is for Dr
Zakir we'll allow the no we a no after
this just two people and one from the
lady no one else would be one one 2 3
four four
question
yeah yeah hello Mr Excuse me Mr T is
saying I should be strict now the thing
is that I'm being compassion I give
chance to two people here now everyone
is demanding a what we allow vote of
thanks right away then four questions
two here one there one there then close
that's final yes Mr danra Sala to
propose a vote of thanks Chief guest YP
trii learned speakers of dialogue
distinguished guests brothers and
sisters it's really my Pleasant duty to
offer vote of thanks on behalf of all
the three organizations on whose behalf
I thank s YP tredi to spare his valuable
time and Grace this occasion as Chief
guest I'm really thankful to both the
speakers for their most interesting and
informative discussion and above all I
thank you all the participants for
participating in the debate thank you
thank you
sir now we continue on with the four
questions the the chief guest Mr tredi
Mr zavi are excused those who would like
to hear the two three or four questions
alloud May sit back we will continue in
a minute as the chief guest and and the
speaker leave the formal program is
closed we will have an informal four
questions allowed for the audiences for
the four question questioners who didn't
get a chance because of my interfering
and giving the other speakers a
chance ladies and gentlemen your
attention please we are starting the
sequel question answer session right
away yes brother my question is are
nonvegetarian food deficient in
nutrition the brothers asked a very good
question
that are non-vegetarian food deficient
in any nutrient yes they are it will be
wrong on my part to say no I'm not a
fanatic nonvegetarian is deficient in
carbohydrate vitamin C but this is
easily available in vegetables nonv have
vegetables and fruits they are rich in
vitamin C we can have fruits but as a
normal comparison in nutritive value if
you analyze the non-v food as I
mentioned earlier it contain contains
first class proteins high
quality and complete protein contains
essential fatty acids even iron and one
of the Good Foods is egg which the
speaker spoke so much against egg egg
the egg contains about six grams of
protein one large egg the half of it is
the egg white and the egg white is known
as an Ideal Protein Ideal Protein me a
protein by which other proteins are
judged it contains all the essential
amino acids in the right quantity
egg also
contains riboflavin ion folate vitamin
B12 vitamin D vitamin E one of the few
only foods which contains vitamin D is
egg egg is given to people who are sick
and are conving who improving from
sickness you know why it's eily digested
contains all the requirement spoke so
much about egg it has little negative
factors also it's also called as
nutrient dense food because it contains
all the essential nutrients in the right
quantity without excess of any one
particular substance and contains less
calorie contains 70 calories only one
large egg but the many foods which
contain essential amino acids which are
not there in the veg food in the veg
food what we have to do if we require
all the nutrients a person can be a veg
and get the nutrients how by selecting
the particular diet by selecting the
vegetable is eating if this vegetable
deficient in one amino acid have the
other vegetable which has it so if he
selectively chooses in the correct
balance and monitors it then he'll be
healthy in non-v food just have very non
food and normally you won't be deficient
in the nutrients hope to answer the
question yes brother my name is babai
Jai Dr Zakir Dr Zakir Nik mentioned in
his speech he tried to quote authorities
alternative to Dr Dean arish Dr Dean
arish has
has been a Pioneer in the field of
research on reversal of heart diseases
and he has now come to be acclaimed as
an authority his contribution to the
field has been recognized by the
president of United States by appointing
him as an adviser to advise Americans on
health matters it is at the instance of
Dr arnish that now it has been
Incorporated in the authoritative
medical textbooks that heart disease can
be reversed through the diet diet which
has been practiced and preached by Dr Dr
arish and Dr and this this particular
diet consists exclusively of vegetarian
food now I would like to know from Dr
Zakir n when he has quoted alternative
authorities what he has to say about Dr
Dean arish research which has cured
thousands of patients of coronary
coronary disease without bypass surgery
Brothers asked a very good question very
relevant question to the point that what
do I have to speak about Dr arish Who's
very
famous and he has said that the heart
disease can be reversed by food which is
only vegetarian food I
agree does it make non-v food
prohibited do you know diabetes malius
brother diabetes malius you don't
require Dr ornish to say if a person is
suffering from diabetes severe diabetes
malius if he doesn't take nonwe
treatment of insulin produced by bne by
pancreas of cow or of pig or human being
he will die
so if a non-v food can cure diabetes
malius that doesn't make veg food
prohibited I agree with Dr
Anish it proves that heart diseases can
be prevented or cured by veg that I
agree but what Mr Rashi said Dr anes
said it should be prohibited as a
general rule for heart patient I agree
people may differ many doctors May
differ I agree I agree but to say
because it cures heart disease nonv
should be prohibited as a general rule
then why isn't America banding nonv food
advisor to American
government adviser to American
government why doesn't the government
take the advis of Dr Anish and stop
non-v food
why what his research is if his
authority he's right but to quote
Authority and then say he band it I
doubt whether doctor Anish ever banded I
doubt I have my doubts show me the
statement where he says that no human
being ever never in this life should I
have any non-v food I challenge you I
challenge you he may say heart
patience there are other authorities I
quoted Dr William T
Jarvis Dr K Jerry several several but I
more more pragmatic I agree with him
it's helpful in curing heart disease not
as a general D hope that answer the
question I'm very
clear yes
sister this is regarding uh since uh Dr
Zakir is a scientist and a doctor
himself so I would like him to enlighten
me on the 15 years of clinical
trial on I didn't get the questions can
you repeat the question 15 years of
clinical trial at the National Cancer
Research Institute at Maryland in USA on
this uh red meat red meat causes cancer
and all those things is it is it
possible for him to enlighten me on this
thank you it's very good question sister
said out of 15 years of research in some
cancer hospital research again not
fact there the difference between
research and fact but I agree with that
research also I've read that research
whether from cancer hospital or which
hospital which she's referring to Aver s
research that it does cause cancer of
the colon excessive eating of nonv
causes cancer of colon if it doesn't
contain diet rich in fiber if the diet
is rich in fiber however much meat you
have it will not cause cancer if it's
combined with excessive eating of non-v
and lack of fibrous diet you know veg
food you eat it can't be digested
because the cellulose can't be digested
it remains as fibers which helps in the
motility excessive eating of nonv with
not eating fibrous diet causes cancer of
colon but if you have the proper
combination everyone having red meat
doesn't have cancer excessive eating
Quran says is
Haram so they're going again the Quran
they're bound to get
diseased that doesn't mean nonv should
be prohibited it should be said
excessive eating of nonv should be
prohibited hope the answer the question
ald thank you very much
[Music]
oh provider of all
things to you we turn each day oh
merciful
Creator only to you we
pray
Allah
[Music]
Allah e